your heart
is good it means you're out of that cave
today we're checking out all the painful
scenes the stranger things cast had to
film from vomiting to slingshots in the
face this young cast was put through the
ringer it's been an experience of a
lifetime number one millie bobby brown
had a serious case of fomo millie found
season four to be the hardest one yet
for filming because she had such a dark
plot in contrast to her co-stars and
found she was separated from them a lot
it's a harder script it's a harder
storyline while that is pretty normal
for stranger things she could see flynn
and some of the others having fun on set
getting to do the more lighthearted
comedic work and she just didn't get to
be a part of it and when you grow up
with your co-stars and they're your best
friends that's rough milly said you get
to see 11 in the darkest state she's
ever been this has definitely been the
hardest season i've ever filmed there
have been some of the scariest scariest
things that i've ever seen as a human
number two well it wasn't its intended
purpose but it works to shoot the scenes
where steve is beat up joe kiri was
already feeling sick and had to have
menthol blown into his eyes to achieve
the desired redness which is fun to look
at and probably less fun to be
vienna listen vic's vaporub contains
menthol and what is vixx for a stuffy
nose so we're pretty sure that's the
excuse they went with when joe
accidentally put it in his eye hey if it
was intentional maybe it helped clear
his sinuses number three joe wasn't the
only one vomiting the a pluribus unum
episode had 11 in the void struggling to
break free from billy's grasp well as
she fell away she twirled around for
this stunt milly was attached to a rig
that spun her in circles millie admitted
physically it was so unbelievably
challenging for me are you okay
okay after a few takes it's no surprise
that this made millie throw up
afterwards she posted about it with the
caption you spin me right round baby
right round threw up after this number
four millie was really spinning before
but now it's just her head that's
spinning shooting inside the sauna was
tough on the whole cast and crew i think
i just threw up in my mouth but it seems
millie took the most of the heat they
spent four full days on a tiny stage
practically the size of a real sauna
with six actors and about a hundred crew
it was squishy and it was super hot and
they shot the scene a million different
ways the scene gone wrong is the scene
that made it into the show when she
collapsed into finn wolfhard's arms that
was due to real exhaustion you can even
see mike break character slightly as he
looks over for help number five millie
might find it too warm but we're gonna
stick around it's quite nice in this
sauna taker montgomery went a little bit
too extreme and smashed his head against
the sauna's glass
you think this
is funny the headbutt was totally
improvised and sadly didn't make it into
the final shot number six let's just say
there's a reason schools don't allow
kids to have slingshots slingshots are
not toys they are weapons meant for
taking out the creepy upside-down
monsters and that's it well caleb
mclaughlin clearly didn't get the memo
and hit himself in the face instead no
ah
number seven we imagine millie was
feeling that fomo around this time too
millie bobby brown split open her
kneecap before filming stranger things
season three so she couldn't do many
stunts or even too much strenuous
movement which included riding a bike
and as we know the cast happens to do
that a lot number eight the prosthetics
king daker had to wear 33 prosthetics
for a time and you know what that means
so did his stunt double that's a lot of
prosthetics at one point it was so hot
and sticky out that daker got himself
stuck to the tablecloth while he was on
lunch and because of millie's knee
injury daker's scenes got moved up which
put a lot of pressure on the makeup crew
to get the prosthetics designed
efficiently sacrifices had to be made
time over quality we had great fun
because i would spend like two hours
every day
getting hair and makeup done and the
prosthetics had such an impact on him
that he realized his body hair wasn't
growing back in certain patches but that
isn't all that was underneath the
prosthetics daker didn't realize he'd
been roughed up as bad as he had been
until he took off all his fake injuries
to reveal real ones underneath daker
admitted i was covered head to toe in
cuts and bruises and i took all the skin
off the top of my toes i just kind of
invest in it number nine while schnapp
may have looked sweaty the only thing
that was burning was his eyes noah
schnapp's black contacts seriously made
his eyes fiery but that wasn't the only
thing that made filming his possession
scene tough it was winter in real life
and his costume was not good for the
weather and the heaters you can see in
the show weren't generating any real
heat ugh what a tease number 10. why
couldn't she have just landed a comedy
or even a simple drama would do the best
way to ruin your acting career is to
obliterate your vocal cords millie had
to scream so much on stranger things
that she lost her voice five times in
eight months but she also had to go back
in for adr and so lost it all over again
we wonder if this halted production or
if they knew these screams would need
healing time and worked the schedule
around them number 11. poor demogorgons
deep down they're just a guy in a
seriously uncomfortable situation the
demogorgon prosthetic outfit was tough
for mark seeger to navigate he had to do
some really difficult stunts in it but
what made it so problematic was his
sight was super restricted too it was so
tough to pull off that eventually they
decided to go with cgi instead it had to
do things a practical guy in a suit just
can't do
number 12. noah more screaming or your
vocal cords might snap we'll see
ourselves out millie wasn't the only one
destroying her vocal cords during one
long night shoot noah had to scream with
everything he had until 6am for the
exercising scene because of course
stranger things likes to get a million
different tangles number 13. we would
rather face a demogorgon than get in a
cold pool millie bobby brown was
submerged in freezing cold water for the
suspension scene despite the crew's best
efforts to keep the water warm it was
just too shallow and got cold too quick
number 14. we never really thought of
filming like groundhog day before but it
really is in some regards joe kiri found
the breakup scene he had to shoot with
natalya to be overwhelming as he hadn't
quite perfected the process of letting
go of his character once the camera
stopped rolling to be broken up with
again and again and again was incredibly
tough for him number 15. don't cry if
you cry then i'm gonna cry and if we're
all crying who's gonna comfort us in
that incredibly emotional goodbye scene
in which the whole cast of kids needed
to somehow manage to bring themselves to
tears they found they didn't need to
rely on sad music or menthol in the eyes
just the thought of actually saying
goodbye one day was enough to do it a
reality that is coming too quickly if
you ask us millie mentioned that one of
the cast of kids proposed imagine if we
had to do this for real one day what if
when stranger things is over we'll all
have to say goodbye to each other and
like this is it and then everyone
started crying and they got the shot the
only thing more painful than any of
these moments will be coming up at the
end of season five the end we're not
ready to think about that yet
distraction technique do you think
millie bobby brown is going to method
with her acting or do you think her
level of intensity is necessary for her
performance to come across as genuine
let us know your thoughts in the
comments and thanks for hanging out with
us here at the things